The most important thing is to eat the ramen while it's hot.
Any good ramen shop will serve you a bowl of ramen that's smoking hot.
And you need to eat it right away because the noodles are overcooking.
It's  a lot like pizza.
If you're a real New Yorker, you know that you don't wait until the pizza cools down.
You eat it while it's hot and you risk burning your mouth.
Ramen is absolutely the same.
You need to slurp.
What it does is it cools down the noodles.
Don't fight the noodles.
Take a little less than you think you want to eat.
You wanna pull them out from the pile...
...because otherwise you'll never be able to slurp.
Easy on the toppings if you're a first-timer.
So, when you order your first bowl of ramen ever, just get it simple.
Taste it.
See if you really like ramen.
And then you can start dumping on the toppings...
...and going for the shop's special of the day.